the startups depend a lot on their
founders and Mark Zuckerberg has
infinite energy and Drive and cleverness
so I wouldn't worry about Facebook yeah
and and how about like everybody else
they read the news about whatsapp and
they thought that's ridiculous to pay 19
bill it's ridiculous that 19 the watsapp
was worth 19 billion dollars not with I
thought I read it like as if someone had
measured the atomic weight of whatsapp
and it turned out to be higher than I
thought right really
whatsapp was worth 19 billion dollars
that's interesting because who knows
better these random people chattering on
forums I won't mention any names right
were like Zuckerberg him scoffs we like
knows all the numbers and is actually
betting this money right people like it
must be worth 19 billion dollars if
Zuckerberg was willing to pay 19 billion
dollars for it because he is no idiot
right yeah so congratulations on the
newfound freedom and a couple of days
off a week it's gonna be antastic for
you it's not the time it's the attention
it's that I won't have to think about Y
Combinator all the time right in order
to build something like this you have to
give up like a lot of cycles there's
this funny like the thing the quote of
mine that people quote the most is that
one about how you can't do a good job at
something without thinking about it in
the shower in the morning I'm like every
time I see this on Twitter I'm like ah
every time every doll I think about in
the shower in the morning is y
combinator right it's taken over my
brain now I'm gonna get my brain back
people I'll take two showers every
morning I'll be so psyched oh you uh you
think you'll ever do your own startup
again no no never why I always say you
are encouraging people and telling them
they have to start sidon unibody right
hey it's just not worth money start a
startup but it's not worth it you money
starting a start-up is the most
efficient way to do it but starting a
start-up hurts like I mean you would
expect it to there's a conservation law
there right like you shouldn't expect
starting a startup to be a great way to
get money and to like feel really easy
and good like like that would be great
wouldn't it yeah it feels great and it's
the easiest way to make a large amount
of money yeah the quickest way yeah yeah
infull isn't it yes and we we don't try
and
like we don't tell founders any other
it's painful right if it's not a certain
amount of painful you're probably not
trying hard enough well that's as good a
notice any to stop on ladies and
gentlemen Paul Graham that was awesome
well done